so today I've got a game for you we're
gonna play a little would you rather I
really can't make you feel any better
because it's choosing between two
difficult things and then briefly
explaining why you would choose oh the
offices alright let's get it over stuff
would you rather screw up every single
take yourself or have somebody else
screw up your best take probably if
someone else screw up my best take
because that means I at least had it in
me to do a best take that's a really
positive spin on it usually I just say
that because like I don't want to have
to feel guilty about it
would you rather sign on for a movie
without reading the script or without
knowing who you're gonna work with
without knowing who I'm gonna work with
because the script has to be amazing you
know you have to fall in love with the
story and then you know you never know
you could have a great script and know
the people that you're gonna work with
and still the movie turns out badly so
you know I I think but having a great
script is key mm-hmm I definitely agree
with that
would you rather would you rather play
the hero or the villain well I mean I
think villains are more exciting in that
sense because there's so many different
facets to their personalities you know
usually they start off good and then
they get Warped through some experience
and they have all these crazy reasons
for doing what they do so it's much more
layered characters so probably villain
and even though she's kind of like the
quintessential villain in this movie
there's still I feel like something to
connect to in terms of her motivations
at least oh there sure is are you
kidding she comes in peace she wants
this incredible you know new world where
everyone lives in unity and equality and
and she gets decapitated and buried
alive so I thought it was very apropos
you know it's intense would you rather
have to run throughout an entire scene
or eat for an entire scene run for sure
I can eat on my off time I believe
nobody thinks about how uncomfortable it
is to actually have to eat in the scene
and then eat for however I know I
learned pretty early
never take a bite a little out of the
would you rather format but because I
think about this a lot
I'm always applauding original stories
on the big screen but at the same time I
think there's great value in keeping a
story alive by remaking it so for
Hellboy in particular or just anything
in general when it comes to remakes what
do you see as the main value in bringing
a story back to screen you know I think
number one somebody the visionary the
director the scriptwriter has to really
want to do it for a certain reason you
know I think when people are passionate
about something they can't go wrong for
the most part so I think somebody's
vision is the most important element and
doing a remake because they obviously
have a reason to do it they wanted to
see it done in a different way they want
to see it done their way so I always
find that fascinating would you rather
see a big screen remake of Resident Evil
or the Fifth Element
ah Fifth Element probably I'd be really
interesting to see how someone else
played Lilu I would be curious I would
be hesitant because I can't picture
anybody else but you out no but it would
be very interesting to see who could try